I mean we have done so many interviews
together this one though Takes the Cake
you are cemented in history with a star
on the Walk of Fame how are you feeling
what does this mean to you it's
I'm a little bit numb right now I think
it's like I'm never good at taking in
the moment when it's right when it's
happening but you know to have something
that's like concrete literally
you know built into the the structure
here you know it's uh it's unbelievable
to have a a star and when I say
unbelievable I I don't I mean it really
is something that I can't believe
because it's not anything that I ever
thought was in the cards for me I didn't
think being on television would ever be
in the cards for me and I know that the
voices is the thing that drove people to
figure out
the music side of what I do you know
which is which is what they say the
category that my star is under which is
makes me super proud you know because
that's what that's what this all started
from and once uh all this goes away one
of these days I'm still just going to be
a country singer you know it's all I
ever wanted to be I've had a dream of of
uh being a country singer and hearing
myself on the radio uh one day and I
never ever thought that that path would
lead me here of course you have your
beautiful family here supporting you
today what do the boys make of this star
it's pretty dang cool cool I think that
they're they're kind of like shocked
because you know there was a moment uh
with uh with Kingston our oldest boy is
about eight months ago uh I forget what
was going on we were just sitting in the
living room and he said and something
came on TV maybe it was a ad for The
Voice or something I can't remember and
he looked at me and he said he said like
sometimes I forget that you're famous I
forget that you that you do that stuff
too you know what I mean and so I I
think today it was like you know it
makes it makes them proud I think it
makes me proud uh and I don't know
so special congratulations like I'm so
proud of you thank you buddy
thank you
another one of my kids right here she's
crying she's proud
[Music]